hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for another Monday morning
podcast for Monday what would that be 16
said Monday the 18th February 18th and
we don't have guests on here too often
what lately more is I've gotten older
here it's starting to lose my mind and I
get self-conscious about you guys
listening to me going on and on and on I
do have a special guest someone I got to
know last year or maybe a little bit
more than a years ago we did a movie
called the front runner please welcome
director extraordinaire Jason Reitman
now I have to admit easy Jason as a fan
of your podcast that I am disappointed
by myself even being here because I hate
when you have a guest on the pocket my
favorite episodes are the ones are just
you and your and you're talking to
yourself and your your best guest and
you go oh really bill yeah and you
really go back and forth so I'm
frustrated with myself being here on
your part okay well don't worry this
thing my listeners fortunately enjoy
movies music and that type of thing so
when I do have people on I don't I try
not to have just some sort of random
person and I'm having you on not only
because I love the movie you made I'm
also in it for a minute so this is a
minute so this is also like self-serving
here you're great in the movie like
you're genuinely great in the movie and
I've gotten a lot of feedback on that
and you're not only in it for a minute
like you play you have you run down an
alley a couple times right you have one
of the best scenes in the film you've
one of the best film and one of the
first things that people ever talk about
is there is the beat where you drop the
the notepad and they start talking about
your scene and your character and I
thought you were fantastic I know and
everybody yeah that was the one thing
that people said like let's just let him
know what it's about in case you know
because god knows there's a million
things to watch Jason directed movie
last year called the the front-runner
which was the Gary Hart story which I
didn't know that up until when he ran
for president that mainstream media
meaning like the New York Times the LA
Times Chicago Tribune whatever like the
newspapers that you your paper boy
delivered never delved into
political candidates personal life as
far as their their affairs or whatever
was going on even if they knew even if
they knew it it was considered beneath
them right
scumbag journalism like National
Enquirer level stuff I had no idea I
guess it was something I never really
thought about like whether they because
growing up I felt like the only person
who ever did it was JFK because that's
what you always heard about him heard
about him Marilyn Monroe yeah but he
never heard about anybody else so I just
sort of assumed that oh he screwed
around there was a couple of legendary
guys that screwed around that screwed
around so much that everybody kind of
knew so I I thought that so I guess I
kind of thought that screwing around was
sort of a new thing or whatever so isn't
that how we feel about sex in general I
mean you know as we get older we realize
that oh that's right more people are
probably pervs than we thought and most
yeah sheet than we thought and you go
back in history oh yeah people have
probably been doing these things yes the
dawn of man time everyone out when I was
really young I was taking drum lessons
from this guy and he was he was 70 then
and I was like 18 or 19 and I was taking
drums he's all big band drummer and he
would started telling me stories one
time he was like oh yeah he goes I used
to have he goes just I knew this this
woman she had green eyes man she was
crazy I used to piece to bang her in the
park up against a tree and I was like
listen this she had a drum lesson I know
well we got to know each other after a
while we'd hang out and stuff so this he
didn't give a [ __ ] he told me because I
was fascinated with his life because I
wanted to on some level it's like wait
is this is what I knew I wanted a fun
job and and I knew I loved drums but I
didn't have it I was like more like dad
rock band sort of talent level but I
didn't know that at that point and I was
fascinated cuz he had lived that life he
in he went through the whole big band
era and all of that and watched that go
away and how he dealt with it and all
that stuff but he used to tell me these
stories and I remember I looked I'm like
you did that looked like a 1930 a 1930s
1940s I'm like you did that and he goes
let me tell you something kid
he goes every gen
raishin thinks they're the first
generation that ever [ __ ] and I was
and I never got that I love the wording
on that tooth that's perfect yeah but
then of course you go back and you know
if you the Romans Greeks and all that
stuff you realize it seems like it was
like like nothing happened like nobody
had sex between the Romans and the
Greeks right up until the Woodstock
right it's kind of how it goes so anyway
so what's-his-face Gary Hart get has an
affair with Donna rice and the Miami
Herald decides to cross that line and
ever since then we now have what we have
now are they just they just delve into
everybody's life and sports it now with
like social media I just thought it was
just such it the way you did it it was
just such a great story considering
everything that's happening now you know
like almost like everything's out there
now to go back and kind of be like this
was sort of like the first like I can't
even say leak in the Dyke this was just
the thing that kind of blew it open ya
know and by the way I didn't know this
stuff either I'm not exactly a student
of history I'm a student of movies I
like movies and I didn't know the story
and I frankly didn't really know who
Gary Hart was you know I was probably 10
when this happened yeah and there was a
radio lab not to plug in different
podcast sorry but I don't read he'll
have it's in a radio lab everybody I did
a piece on this story Matt by had
written a book about Gary Hart and that
really was my introduction to the story
and considering everything that we're
going through right now and considering
the way that we've kind of thinned the
line between what is a private life and
what is a public life and I thought this
story was fascinating that there was a
moment where as you just said he's his
private life was out of balance it was
considered not only uncouth but it just
wasn't our business and he was a guy who
was actually a great candidate in every
other respect
you know two-term senator and was kind
of just that not only the presumed
nominee but presumed to win you know he
was like ten points ahead of George Bush
going into the campaign plus we just had
eight years of a Republican so that's
what happens it ever he's like oh it's
it's the red ties fault right he goes
then you go eight years this way then
eight years that way so yeah
and and this story kind of broke though
so basically yeah you're right other you
know people kind of knew about Gary Hart
that I think there was kind of
presumptions that perhaps he was a
womanizer that perhaps he dated around
you know he'd been separated from his
wife a couple times and so he had he had
kind of just dated traditionally in DC
and and the Miami Herald what his dated
traditionally means he's separated I
mean it wasn't there was a moment where
he wasn't married he was just kind of
going on dates and so people got a feel
for what this guy is like as as a
bachelor guy crushes it at work he
crushes it outside he was a handsome guy
I mean the best friend was Warren Beatty
I mean you know oh wow yeah there you go
so the Miami Herald gets wind of this
and they they followed it up and when a
lot of other newspapers said you know
we're not gonna we're not gonna cover
this the Miami Herald did and the
American public said yes give me more of
that and it coincides with just a lot of
things happening simultaneously you know
it was just a few years before that CNN
even like went on the air they started
crossfire this the the satellite van was
invented a Current Affair the first
gossip television show you know goes on
goes on the air said so the you know
what we think of as you know National
Enquirer being a print medium like made
it to television right and now we're
filling a 24-hour news cycle and the
American public said yeah that that
matters to us we want to we want to hear
that was also - back then before the
24-hour news channel you had time this
right [ __ ] was coming out you at least
you know if it was eight the more like
this [ __ ] story it's breaking in 11
hours we got it we got it or whatever 10
hours we got to do something here and
now you have like forget about the 24
hours so you have social media and now
also the way people post news there's no
alleged it's like somebody gets accused
of something and then regular people
because they're not in journalism and
then I guess there's there's no libel or
anything on the Internet it's just be
you know so-and-so accused of this and
then it's like the next you know
generation of that piece of [ __ ] blah
blah blah blah blah did this and oh
sorry that's me
[ __ ] this is literally this is the part
of the podcast that you enjoy when I
[ __ ] go onto my phone here yeah and
completely abandoned 175 pounds will say
there we go is this your way in no I'm
doing Santa Barbara tonight and I'm
flying the helicopter up with my
instructor and I thought we were only
gonna get the two-seater now the four
seater became available so I'm asking if
my buddy can go along so he just needs
to know how many is there gonna be and
how much he weighs because it's all
weight and bow anytime you rent a
helicopter or take a helicopter you have
to admit your weight does that talk with
people yeah you know what it's funny
because especially in this business with
entertainers yeah because I had a buddy
of mine he goes and he was sort of fat
at the time fatter than he wanted to be
and he goes dude I'll be like 190 by the
time we fly I think he was over two
bills and he didn't want to admit it and
I just said I just said dude this is not
a time to lie okay baggies like 206 but
I'm gonna be in the 190s by the time we
fly it's like great just don't you know
don't gain any more weight or whatever
and what they do is I'll just adjust
like 5 pounds up or something like that
I would think and they're moving weight
around the helicopter to balance it left
for a top bottom and then how much fuel
you can have like there was a there was
some kid who was inexperienced or
whatever and he filled up the thing that
I was I'm gonna fly the r44 so it's a
four passenger when you have a four
passenger I mean unless you have kids
you know I haven't flown this thing much
I'm just repeating what people told me
you never fill both tanks up full cuz
you just have too much weight and you
won't be able to get lift and I don't
know I hate this guy even got into a
hover but somehow he did and he took off
and then it just becomes this thing
where you just pull in too much power
and you're you're you start descending
and then your brain tells you pull more
what you actually wanna do is try to
level out what she probably should have
done was something called a running
landing which is sort of sliding into
second base yeah which he did not do and
unfortunately it didn't end well that
day so that's why we're asking he's
asking how many more it's only one only
one is not a big deal and also he's in
he's like a buck 75 so it won't be a
problem but it will
definitely you know I would think he
wouldn't top off both at this point but
but it's not that long a flight my DP is
a pilot my center part was a pilot a lot
of my camera crew or pilots right and on
up in the air which we did with American
Airlines mm-hmm they took the whole
camera team down to Dallas at the end of
the shoot and they have I guess this
warehouse where they have a cockpit
simulator for every plane they have in
there Wow and they just holding them in
two planes and these cockpits are real
common they are completely outfitted
that it comes millions of dollars and
they're so good that if you if you get
certified on the simulator you are ready
to take passengers up in the air like
there is no in-between as soon as you're
certified on the assumed no but I don't
understand about that is how do they
duplicate the feel of whatever you're
flying and how do they duplicate like
turbulence and they're not then not only
that yeah you know no matter what you're
not gonna die in that thing right oh
you've never had to mentally try to keep
your [ __ ] together Ossipee so I would
think you you have to go up with
somebody you got it I don't think they
got all right buddy
yeah so if you're Space Invaders [ __ ]
certificate eric says my center part of
Eric he he said he's never sweat more in
his life he said you forget that it is
fake the moment it is happening cuz it's
all wow if the whole thing is shaking
the whole time the whole thing can
rotate and move and shake they got
screams all around so all you see is
what you would be normally seeing
outside the window I gotta do that and
what they did is they were just [ __ ]
with them the whole time so with each
one of the guys on my camera team they
would just throw everything up like
burst yeah and left engines out you know
a bird just went through your tornado
coming they give everyone the Sully
route to see if they could no one no one
to kill every was just crashing in the
river and oh god yeah oh that's in
Dallas huh yeah and then when we were
shooting frontrunner we were over at
Delta and they said Delta's in Atlanta
and I member on a lunch break the guys
did the same thing he's dad and I missed
out I didn't know this was going down
they came back from lunch and Erik with
his hands were shaking he said it's just
it's
so real you forget that you're in a
simulator and it is that right well
hopefully somebody listens to this and
lets me try to do something like that
because I always ever since like 9/11
with those you know the terrors taken
over the plains you have your Steven
Seagal fantasy that you would take them
all out right then in my fantasy the
pilots are also taken out and then
that's where it ends it's like are you
like a fire plane no okay now and I
don't and there's a lot of stuff that is
involved with it that I don't understand
that does fascinates me as far as their
flaps and that type of stuff is how far
is like you know because the way think
about aviation is you kind of learned
through people [ __ ] up and most of
the time those fuck-ups lead to death
and it's not something that you want to
it's like it's I'd equated to like
riding a motorcycle where if you know if
you'd sell you only you only person want
to talk to you about riding a motorcycle
somebody else who rides a motorcycle
because they'll talk about the fun of it
where to go anybody else not a matter
well you know it matters I had a winner
same thing with like aviation which is
not a fair comparison because of how
safe it is mm-hmm
I mean there's always obviously an
element of danger every time you do it
but like the just the sheer amount of
people that are up there versus down
here there's nobody up there texting and
right and also the level of training and
the level of just communication that
goes on when you're up there I mean that
that's what always blows my every flight
is when I then go down the highway and
you know out here upwards of six lanes
of breast and it's just like I'm
literally flying in formation right now
on the ground looks painful
I don't know what the flight plan is I
don't what they're gonna do people are
just ignoring the rules like those
people who pass you on the right doing
like 94 miles an hour and you're trying
to get off and I can't tell you how many
times I've landed mmm got in my car and
then got on the highway and seen an
accident that's happened like four times
I saw the craziest accident that it I
was on the ten and two cars trying to
merge into the same Lane
they both notice each other at the same
time and they don't touch their cars
never make contact but they both freaked
out by how close they are to overcorrect
yeah and one overcorrects left goes into
the median the
/ crooks right rolls their car Oh Ross
up into a sign up onto the dirt and I'm
just behind them three quarters between
both of them and just go right between
them it was episode of the fall guy it
was like transform it was so crazy and
they never touched each other was the
freakiest thing it was like the hand of
God it was it spooked me for a while
after go change I remember early in my
career I I did a road gig with a comic
who had broken his hip in a car accident
and he drove like an old lady and like I
was like what the [ __ ] and then I
started driving and I could just feel
him how nervous he was and that was the
first time that clicked in my head the
physics of what I was doing like I this
cars going 80 so am I you know I'm going
80 miles on you just don't think it you
just sitting there cruising along and
all you're gauging is what's in front of
you and well it's clear so it doesn't
feel like you're going 80 miles and like
I'm going my body is traveling at a rate
that if I was to hit something and stop
abruptly my brains gonna slam against
the inside of my skull and I'm gonna be
dead like that's just not something that
I think and this happens in aviation too
when when guys get higher in higher
hours is you get that false sense of
safety like they what I heard in ground
school was the most dangerous pilots
were the people with very few hours and
then people with a ton of hours right
because then they would get lazy with
their pre-flight you know because you
know they never had an engine failure
never yeah yeah it's fine it's fine it's
fine
let's go [ __ ] load it up you're fine
what do you a [ __ ] buck 67 to get in
the [ __ ] thing and you know just just
doing dumb [ __ ] you know why aren't
there more it's funny when I think about
it there's plenty of stories horror
stories about musicians on the road and
so many musicians have died plane
crashes car crash if you just kind of
you just in your mind I say that you can
kind of instantly list like 20 of them
right I don't know those stories about
comic the comics are on the road just as
much because we fly commercial most of
most of those guys I think that died a
lot of those they were they were
chartering planes like the the day the
music died yeah like that was the whole
thing let's get that and all that was
because I remember
I laid that room the Surf ballroom and I
flew in the airport the whole thing is
like Jude you are flying in that airport
go get like they think it's the airport
you know it's like no what happened was
as far as what I read was just the
technology for de-icing just was not
there so he had the added weight on his
wings of the ice and then also the ice
just the layer of it changes the shape
of the wing which affects your level of
lift and he had those two devastating
combinations and then the end result of
that equation was they all died so yeah
I don't know that there's I think the
Leonard Skinner was another one I think
Aerosmith had just charted that plane or
was gonna chart that was a [ __ ] plane
you see they found Aerosmith's original
tour van no apparently they'd they found
like original like tiny tour van with
like spray-painted on the side or
something like how does that exist for
that long for so somebody just doesn't
know quite what just think that whoever
bought it had no idea who Aerosmith was
right it says it on the side of the van
yeah just had it in the back and like I
don't know if that was a bread crumb
company or what it's that [ __ ] that's
that's that should be in like the Rock
and Roll Hall of rhyme or something the
sets from 2001 sat in a field forever in
in England like all these old spaceships
and and spacecraft and things that they
build miniatures but were just enormous
majors apparently were sitting in a
field for years any lund that's what I
find fascinating about when I was
talking to you when we had the time when
we do in frontrunner was talking to you
about growing up in this business right
and when I listen to you talking about
movies and movie sets I was fascinated
you sound like me the way I talked about
sports and in football cards and guys
who played in old stadiums and that type
of stuff and did your parents ever try
to discourage you from getting into this
business I would say that a lot cuz I
don't think I would do that to my
daughter because I just look at it like
this isn't an incredibly fun business
it's it's really hard and it's very
competitive but so I think if you're
gonna try to get to the top of any
business you're gonna deal with that
same
thing it's not like trying to become the
greatest oil man or politics or the best
lawyer I would think that all of that
becomes cutthroat the higher up you're
going up the mountain so I mean if
you're really into this this business I
mean I just plus I also don't think it's
as bad as it used to be as far as now
with like all of this the power that the
individual has on social media that if
somebody is a creep because that was the
big thing especially you had a daughter
like you're not getting in this business
yeah casting couch all of those horror
stories of that [ __ ] now I think it's
it's a I've just declared on my podcast
that it's it's it's okay now that's how
I do it I mean honestly I think the the
rejection the the potential for
rejection is more dangerous than I guess
partying and all that stuff I think if I
you know if my daughter was thinking of
going into business that would be my
biggest fear is just going to a business
where you know decade by decade you're
being told you're worthless you're told
that you're valueless on a daily basis
that's no way to live but right my
parents actually how do you think that's
literally said oh that's just something
that gets in your head by not booking
auditions yeah I mean unlike any other
business where you can kind of see you
know judge your own wares by how you're
doing this is a business yeah you go to
audition after audition or you write
something one after and you don't really
have a sense of why you're not being
picked or why your works not being made
and so you start to second-guess and
look in the mirror and go oh is it this
is it that you know is it because I wore
this is because I'm too heavy is it you
know maybe I need to look more like this
person or sound more like this person oh
yeah I want to do all of that but I
think that's the fork in the road where
you can really get go into a deep
depression which I did or you can grow
from it where you just go like you know
what [ __ ] this this is what I do this is
what I look like and that's how once
like I went to that mindset this is what
I do this is what I look like if you
want to book me awesome if you don't I
understand there's all kinds of
beautiful people out there yeah always I
mean and one thing I've learned from
listening your podcast though is that
you have and I'm not sure if this
developed earlier or later but you have
a strong sense
self-reflection and and and and you
probably don't like be saying this but I
think you're you're incredibly
thoughtful when it comes to that and and
really health out easy
compliments are not allowed yeah no I
know I know I'm sorry I know I know I do
I'm um yeah Nia's telling me I have to
get better at doing that so thank you I
appreciate but there was I went through
in the okay so when I started the look
was it was just the post 80s but that
look was still around the sport cope
with the Miami Vice colored t-shirt and
the sleeves pulled up a little bit and I
remember my mother got me a sport coat
to wear on stage and I knew it would
look good but I didn't think I was good
enough to wear it so I don't that's the
Catholic guilt or whatever so I never
wore it you got me I didn't I didn't
[ __ ] lace I didn't think I was good
enough to dress like a hacky [ __ ]
Road comic yeah because at that point it
was like 93 and 94 so that look was way
out and like is that jacket like still
at your folks house or you know I'm
trying to think where that I I think I
might add that one month it might be at
my parents house or it was it was given
away or something but then the the
grunge thing came in so everybody had to
have their shirts untucked and then the
late 90s was a real moose era there was
a lot of moose in the hair Oh got it
and I remember you know that was back in
the days of the black and white photos
right so I had booked a little bit of
acting work early in my career and if
you're young and you book anything I
booked a commercial something like that
all of a sudden they're just like oh
Jesus well you know this must be the
next young horse we can ride so they
started I had a little buzz you know new
guy in New York whatever so I would hand
out you know they handed out my photos
and this back when I had hair and with
the mousse and the hair my hair looked
Brown so on some lower budget [ __ ] they
would bring me in for like the lead or
something and there was sort of an
unwritten rule that redheaded males are
just you're not the lead you're the
friend so I would walk in you know
prepared like the three scenes or
whatever and they'd come walking in
their face and drop be like okay we're
just going to do the first scene and
that happened a million times
but i but I prepared a nobody we're just
yeah
maybe if you read for his friend or
something and I it was funny because I
never quite got frustrate because I knew
what was going on I figured it out after
a you know a couple times of that
happening like oh I get it I look like
[ __ ] Ron Howard and they think you
know I'm not this guy and I just always
had in my head eventually I'm going to
get that part mhm and but my goals were
all stand-up related anyways and I knew
that my stand-up was gonna lead to me
meeting you know someone like you and
hopefully getting a partner in a movie
so that's what I ended up doing I just
focused on stand up and stand up and
stand up and stand up and then
eventually I pushed through and I think
I would say Vince Gilligan was the first
guy with Breaking Bad I finally got the
play an [ __ ] yeah I think I got to
play an [ __ ] and I liked what I liked
about playing that [ __ ]
was I had Huell so I didn't have to act
tough right it's like I got this guy so
I just had to be the reason why come on
man this guy is gonna get upset just for
that song say that I remember actually
on set because there's a dynamic that
was in my head I think that's often
happened to the director I sang in their
head but they're not gonna be
communicating it enough to the actors or
whoever and I had this dynamic in my
head of what you and Steve's assist were
to each other right and I remember the
moment where you suddenly got what I
would why I thought the two of you would
be great together like why I thought
this was an interesting comic pairing as
two people at a newspaper who worked
together right now one guy who your
character who had under actually done a
lot of undercover work and was kind of
more tough as nails but but also maybe
talking it up a little too much and then
the other guy who have never been
undercover had never done an any type of
investigation and and what that work
would be like together
when I was a fun guy to be that guy like
saying that he did more than he did as I
go the other way I under plain and
that's and I'm telling you that comes
from where I was born in the world
growing up just outside of Boston
Massachusetts you know look in the way I
did with [ __ ] orange hair and [ __ ]
the move was underplaying
self-deprecation
funny yourself before was on you make
the bigger kids who can beat the [ __ ]
out of you laughs so they like you and
in that moment when they're gonna beat
somebody up they look at you and then
move on to the next kid that's what it
was all about was just getting it off of
me it was like what was that game the
Wonder ball you know when you were kid
the Wonder ball goes round and round
just making sure when that song ended
you weren't holding all net yeah you
weren't holding the ball so you know
it's funny in my school the redheaded
guy in my class uh-huh was the tough guy
was his name was Paris Cronin he was the
son of the lead singer for REO
Speedwagon he was the tough guy he was
easily the the toughest dude in class
he's probably a sweetheart now but he
was a bully back then and so that was my
association with redhead through
elementary school that's why I love
about kids who grew up in like Hollywood
in LA out here like the people you went
to [ __ ] is why I love being out here
it's not meeting the guy it's meeting
the relatives or something like I mean
once I went to a Super Bowl party and I
met this guy his grandfather played the
guy who was in the bed with the horse
head in the gun like whenever people
like [ __ ] on LA gunner Lee there's a
bunch of phonies and blah blah yeah it's
like everything has in it there's a
phone enos to every industry especially
when there's money involved but when you
get out here there's an extremely
talented people and creative people and
then you get like great like moments
like that like I know a comic I started
off with in in Boston Tony V I don't
remember this you remember that those
old luggage commercials that was it the
tourists or commercials or whatever and
there was the gorilla
throwing of the luggage around inside
the cell vague memory yeah yeah yeah he
played the gorilla so that was one of my
first like cool stories he told me I was
on the road with them I was like that
was you in the suit he's like yeah that
was me let's get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm with the [ __ ] gorilla suit guy
throwing the the luggage around so I was
doing a scoring session for a movie and
there was a stand-up bass guy there's
two stand-up bass guys actually one was
the younger one was a little bit older
and and they were doing this one solo
piece for me we were in the mixing stage
and the younger guy goes do you even
know who this other guy is
and I said Knapp's you know I don't and
the younger guy goes just show him just
show him and the other guy goes okay and
he starts going then it ended in doing
that in the end and he had played the
opening baseline for Nancy Sinatra is
these boots made walk get the [ __ ] it
was incredible
that was over at Capitol that wasn't a
cow but this was on a different movie
world on her at the time and and it's
like holy [ __ ] and yeah it's like where
did that come from he's like you know I
was just trying different things out we
tried that and it worked and it's like
that's one of the most iconic bass lines
yeah and you just shook his head you
shook the hand that played every time
just did it for me it was great yeah and
every time you hear it as always I go on
tangents on here so getting back to the
movie where can people see this because
that was the thing it came outside well
we came out and over but this is the
thing though it's not like no one saw it
it's just it hasn't been where people
can are gonna see it and I feel like
what I'm starting to realize as little
as I know about this whole movie game is
that people nowadays like to get him to
go out to theaters it has to be like a
big Aquaman marble thing it seems or
like it like a chick flick like that
star is born it has to be an event of
some kind
yeah they get you to get you outlets
it's expensive I mean look it's gonna
cost fortunate go to the movies and and
you have to have a real reason you want
to want to go with people and and now
the size of these freaking flat-screen
tvs it's like you really do have like
your own movie scream no one's going to
be talking you can hit pause so this
movie the front-runner is a great one to
sit down and watch without you know the
distractions of going to the movie
theater I think and and what I love what
I [ __ ] loved about this movie when I
finally saw it was how you don't do that
[ __ ] thing that I hate in movies
where you lead people around and like
you have a point now I'm trying to make
and you know and and I'm gonna you know
you know if even have half a brain you
know what the point is as the movies
starting and then you're gonna hit me
over the head with it for a hour and a
half two hours your thing is just sort
of like hey
this happened and and you know you can
kindness it's not you know are there's
certain people that would have done that
had been like and if he got elected yes
no Robert Walker we're not in Iraq and
all of America works out and it's just
kind of like now this [ __ ] happened
and ever since then all this other stuff
is happening and is is this you know one
of the questions that I was left with
that is does this type of [ __ ] make
qualified probably better candidates not
run because they have their priorities
straight like my family's more important
than putting them through this [ __ ] and
does it does it more attract just a
singer Lee focused almost I don't wanna
use sociopaths because that's always
overused but like more of a psycho
selfish [ __ ] person where they're
gonna be like yeah [ __ ] I don't know I'm
not even thinking about my kids well you
might want this if you look at the
diversity evenly Gary Hart and Bill
Clinton Gary Hart was a guy who said I'm
just not gonna dignify these questions
with an answer and Bill Clinton was a
fighter and that's when he became
president it's because he's a guy who'd
just fought back whether that's a good
or bad quality but look I'm not a guy
who believes in good or evil that's not
why I make movies so that's interesting
to me so what is your cuz I often think
that you know we're like with religion
that I grew up in it's like if you do
this you do this in to do this you're
going to hell unless you confess it but
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh and then you have to
be sincere in confession but I sit there
and I like from my religion I always
think I'm going to hell
yeah but then I look at my friends right
and we've all roughly know your friends
are roughly living the same life you do
I look at them and I think all of them
are going to heaven we're all flawed
right and and and look I love Star Wars
as much as the next guy I love Star Wars
and I look forward to every Star Wars
films and those movies are all about
good and evil and I appreciate superhero
films but you know so far the kinds of
movies that I've been making have not
been about good and evil they've been
about nuanced even about I live in the
middle and and and frankly I think that
life is more complex than that you can't
judge person any person by one moment
but we are living right now in a time
when everyone is judged by one moment
a millisecond and you know you say one
wrong thing and the rest of your life is
kind of thrown down the drain and we
lose qualified people because of that
and then I also love people who then
pile on and use that person's [ __ ] is
a way to show how awesome they are
exactly the amount of people that have
used these the victims of sexual assault
the amount of people who have used that
as a platform to show how I hate to use
this word woke they are and like look
I'm on the right side of this and I'm a
lie and all those Dell
that-that-that-that jargon that has come
out of that thing and you said something
earlier about how Gary Hart was I'm not
going to dignify that and you know
somebody's personal life is none of
their business and I've felt that my
whole life and I still feel that and
there's been times you know someone's
wanted to show me something it's just
like dude that's that's none of my
[ __ ] business especially you know
like texting between two people mm-hmm
and somebody like somehow gets that I
always think like the story here is who
got that and what a legal way they got
that like why did you or anytime any
shitty friend they are yeah and what why
does anybody like anytime anybody gets
arrested and that the TMZ somehow gets
the mugshot it's like why isn't there an
investigation to find out who's the cop
that [ __ ] let that thing out and with
a mob like the monkey yeah that's why we
have like I'm so no but that no that's
one of those things that that is public
but but you're right there's plenty that
is that is nuanced and more complicated
and it kind of gets thrown under the rug
and what's interesting about the Hart
story and why we made the front runner
is it brings up ten different
conversations it's talking about not
only the relationship between
journalists and politicians and why we
vote for certain people it's bringing up
all kinds of gender politics questions
that have changed since that moment and
like what the idea of a whistleblower is
because Donna rice wasn't a
whistleblower no like it's easy to
forget that that there have been
whistleblowers who are women who are
bravely coming forward and talking about
what kind of dirtbags they've dealt with
Donna rice was a private human being its
religion Gary Hart and honor eyes were
two very religious people
very private people who wound up in a
very public moment because we all
thought it was our business when neither
of them to this day have spoken about it
yeah I didn't even know that that's
amazing
yeah Donna rice never sold her story
that's cool she hunts then right there
then she's alright she's like she's like
a mobster who never told on the other
mobsters and just went to jails at a bad
analogy did I [ __ ] up no no not at all I
mean she's complex I mean she's it's
interesting because I I think there's
probably a lot of liberals that went to
if they saw frontrunner they want to
kind of take up the torch with Donna
rice and then they find out that she's
she's on the right wing and she's
actually you know pro-life and she's I
love when that happens
this so and there's so many do you know
like we don't blew my mind the other day
was there was a story about a guy in New
York who killed this pregnant woman and
she was early on pregnant and you know I
forget because of some new abortion law
they couldn't get they couldn't get him
on two murders it was the whole thing
was [ __ ] weird but the whole gray
area in that I know I know I only have
like half the [ __ ] details here it
was something about it she was pregnant
this guy killed her and people were
upset that that because of some new
abortion laws they called it double
homicide you'd be saying that that is
life in the womb and if it's life in the
womb then you cannot have an abortion
because that would be murder that's then
it becomes this whole thing like okay so
but if she wants to have an abortion
then it's not a life so it's basically
life if the woman decides like I was
sitting there like the amount of like
mental flip-flop and I was doing going
like so what is going out like there was
such like a really you know I mean
obviously it's a horrible thing that
happened but it was it was interesting
religiously legally and like social
media way like lettuce Isaac Lanham like
now that well how the [ __ ] do you
navigate that minefield if you're
pro-choice
yeah okay and you said yeah that's just
a fetus that's not a life but if a guy
comes in and kills somebody then now
because she wanted to keep it then it is
a life then it is the taking of life
then it becomes like well wait a minute
so what do we [ __ ] say in here saying
thank God I don't
have to figure that kind of thing yeah
we're living like you imagine having to
be the person who has to decide that no
because I'll be honest with you like my
I have my opinions on abortion but like
I had I always preface them with like I
have no [ __ ] idea what the right
answer is here because I look at it one
way it's like well if if it's not the
taking of a life that but if you didn't
have that procedure there would have
been another life you know barring a
miscarriage or something like that so
something was ended there but then on
the other side you look at like you look
at what the population control and like
the way we're polluting the planet and
how that's affecting all these other
babies that are alive and I think it's
just there's like a million [ __ ] ways
that you can look at it so I just sort
of resigned it to like whatever somebody
feels is so is the right thing to do if
they're cool with that you know then
then I'm fine with it
I am a pro-choice then I mean that's
choice then because that yeah you're
talking about his choice because I don't
know I wouldn't do it right - kind of
yeah but you're talking about someone's
right to choose themselves which I agree
with you about people need personal
freedom yeah I also don't like people
telling me what the full but I don't
might add something some of it I don't
mind like you know I like this his laws
if you want to kill somebody and it's
not me I mean Who am I to say that that
guy didn't deserve it no all right
taking a little break here it's time for
a little bit of advertising a by the way
thank you to everybody came out in Santa
Barbara in Pasadena and in our Riverside
I really appreciate it I had a great
time at all of those shows and I got to
come home and sleep in my own bed
unbelievable alright here's some [ __ ]
reads for you dear helix everybody
there's nobody on the planet like you
you're so special you're a warrior
you're living your best life so why
would you buy a generic mattress built
for everyone else especially a white
male next please mention all the taking
taking points to talking points below oh
absolutely
helix sleep built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete and they
use the ances to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the mattress
you're asleep a side sleeper a hot
sleeper Jesus it's getting weird here
like a plush or firm bed with hell
experience there's no more guessing or
confusion just go to helix sleep calm /
bird take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a mattress
while they build your robot replacement
that will give you the best sleep of
your life four couples helix HELOCs can
even split the mattress down the middle
like a divorce providing individual
support now as a divorce you get the
whole bed because she's used to a big
mattress lifestyle providing individual
support needs and field preferences for
each side that's right feel preferences
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 200 bucks off mattresses mattress
orders for their Presidents Day sale get
up to $200 at helix sleep calm / /
that's HELOCs sleep calm / / for $200
off your mattress order for their
Presidents Day sale going on right now
helix helix helix sleep calm / / h e li
x oh look who's here everybody its old
zip hiring used to be hard something an
old man talking about his dick multiple
job sites stacks of resumes a confusing
review process but today hiring can be
easy and you only have to go to one
place to get it done zip recruited calm
/ / well old zip sends you job to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip that
was the Marco Polo one scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job as applications come in
yeah analyzes each one and spots likes
the spots lights the top candidates so
you never miss a great match zip is so
effective that 80% of employees who post
on zip get a quality candidate through
the site within the first day and right
now my listeners can try zip read for
free at this exclusive website address
zip recruiter comm / / that's it for
cooter comm / / zip girl.com / / that
was the falling off the clip reed zi p r
ec r UI ter the smartest way to hire all
right movement MVM t now now it's time
and now it's time to move on to our
all-time favorite underdog success story
evidently MV mt movement watch is
founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank they've sold
almost 2 million watches worldwide by
bringing quality designs and a fair
price movement watches are all about
looking good while keeping it simple
they don't tell you how many steps you
take in a blow your blow one or blow
your wrist up with text messages
parentheses you up oh the old booty call
and the wrists there may be funny if you
rubbing one out and then that came in
it's like oh I don't need to do this now
they're not overly intrusive on life
with notifications text messages emails
etc they tell time like true classic
timepieces should looking good doing it
movement watches start is just 95 bucks
you're looking at $400 for the same
quality from a traditional brand talk
about all the things you can buy with
the save money let's see four hundred
minus nine is three hundred and five
dollars well I didn't want to tell you
what I first thought of my came saying
it was something that was a pro choice
that you could pay three quarters of
movement has almost two million watches
in over a hundred six
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement dot-com /lz movement launches
new styles on their site all the time
check out their latest MV mt @ m vm t
com go to movement comm / / join the
movement MV m t.com / / alright let's
get back to the interview here with the
wonderful jason reitman but anyway so
now we're gonna be mentioned where can
people see this [ __ ] amazing movie
that you made with Hugh Jackman and Vera
Farmiga the two of them I was watching
this [ __ ] con they're gonna get they're
gonna get nominated for summit that's it
it's a [ __ ] just weird time in in this
business where a movie like yours it can
can slip through the cracks in cinema
but the great thing though is it can now
be on like a Netflix or something like
that in life and it can explode so it's
not even like so the jury's still out as
far as where it's so viable it's on
iTunes on iTunes where you can get the
DVD and it's a love letter to 1970
cinema so if you happen to be you know a
cinephile like me and you do that stuff
and you did guys like Robert Altman and
Michael Richie I mean this is a love
letter to their movies there's lots of
these crazy long you know wonders and I
love those shots but yeah I feel
especially with the people way people
edit now where they make everything look
like the [ __ ] Bourne Identity yeah
which works for the Bourne Identity but
I have this theory that when you edit
really quick like that it's like you're
flipping through channels and it makes
your brain reset reset reset and where
the long holding shots draws you in like
I kind of learned that when I was first
started doing stand-up specials I would
look at the old ones and be like why
does this look so [ __ ] real and
everything from today looks fake now
part of it was HD because it you know HD
can get like clearer than real life like
you guys on a soap opera yeah like your
blue sweater all of a sudden I'm not
even listening to you oh my god look how
blue is sweaters you know but then the
other thing was the pacing of it was
just bam bam specially in the 2000s it
was a really bad time for stand-up
specials where there was just the
lot of like great comics where I heard
the what I felt that the editing hurt
the material where you would just have
directors just like just shooting their
[ __ ] load of every every camera I
mean I watched a special literally like
a guy walking out to the microphone the
guy showed every camera he had right
we're in front of him were behind him
I'm at the top of the theater I'm
swooping in the jibs my favorite thing
ever ever in a in a stand-up special why
am i swooping in to my [ __ ] joke right
nothing and else nothing less like I'm
in the audience then I'm flying over the
audience I hate that yeah well we talked
about the idea I think you brought the
idea up to me was you know could we
shoot a comedy special on film shoot it
like an old Rock doc yeah I mean I made
a short a short documentary on roast
battle that they do up in the the
Valhalla that gets crazy at them and
that was fun we shot a black-and-white
and made it all grainy and made it look
punk-rock and I was that was a lot of
fun welcome people see that you put that
out you know I you know I've kept that
one secret I we brought it to Sundance
and a played there and if I know someone
I'll just send them a link so they can
watch it because I think it's really
cool but yeah I don't know why I've kept
that one I've kept that one tight but
that's something you'll use I don't know
I just I just I just I love the
roustabout I love what they do up there
I love that it's one of the few rooms
that is just honest anymore when I go in
and watch that and it's this tight room
there's a league only hold you know less
than 100 people yeah and it's it's also
it's Tuesday at midnight so the only
reason you're there is if you really
need to be there yeah and and it's the
least prejudiced room and most
prejudiced room I've ever been in my
life yeah I actually actually was there
Tuesday night doing it run in my hour
because I'm gonna be doing this taping a
special and it's just one of those great
comedy things where I forget her name
the woman who was running the show but
she was great but it did the the crowd
was very progressive yes I should and
that's in quotes because progressive
just means think what we think or we're
going to attack you yeah not progressive
so I went up there and I was doing my
[ __ ] and oh my god I was
[ __ ] bombing so bad for like the
first ten minutes before I kind of you
know got out I was making fun of
Michelle Obama doing the arena tour
mm-hmm which is just [ __ ] hilarious
to me and I knew that that they were all
going to be I got you the inspiration so
I just had so I was trashing her even
harder but it was just one of those
things that makes the Comedy Store great
and makes stand-up comedy great where
it's just like like I was up there
bombing and I was having the best [ __ ]
attack I was annoying the crowd so bad
that there was a woman in the crowd
pretending to be asleep on her friend's
shoulder like that was gonna I was gonna
enter your skin I saw my god and I loved
it and I just kept I kept talking to her
to the point she had to pretend to wake
up and then I was critiquing her soap
opera acting I was like okay now in this
take let's do it this way and what's
funny is I've been doing this shift for
27 years it's like do you think that's
the first [ __ ] time some words I
remember I remember the first time that
it happened me the old Boston comedy
club and there was these two big black
women in the front row and one of them
just like put her head down on the other
one and but this is the thing I was
bombing during that set to but I was
bombing in a bad way
I was bombing like I'm not funny what
the other night I was bombing like you
got old
well you're not receptive to my material
and I know that so then I'm just gonna
go like even harder I saw you do it
before you and I met and in a moment we
should talk about our first conversation
when you got to set because I don't
think you knew who I was I thought you
was somebody else that was it made me so
happy you have no idea so I thought you
were gonna be like why did I hire this
guy what a [ __ ] war I know you know
he's spectacular so I saw you do you
remember TIG Notaro had a show at Largo
uh-huh and you did that show and it was
very similar I mean he was takes crowd
and takes brilliant and her crowd no
she's why I say it's yeah one of my
favorite her audience is obviously gonna
be very left-wing and and I watched you
do this kind of set where you realized
oh the audience is just so uncomfortable
with anything other than left-wing
material and because of that they don't
know if they're allowed to laugh you
just came right at the audience with
Fearless Lee and with confidence and
nose was a delight what Stig's fans
they're not really violent so I wasn't I
didn't have to be too fearless if it was
I was opening for I don't know a couple
other comics I can think of they have a
more aggressive like I wouldn't I
wouldn't be fearless in front of a Joe
Rogan crowd cause I would figure a lot
of them know that UFC stuff and I would
be afraid to piss somebody off in the
crowd because those guys are no joke
Tigs audience who's gonna get a stern
letter well they might end your career
if they might start a hashtag if you say
the wrong thing I mean oh I might get
put on the sidelines I don't know it's a
really weird thing and there's
definitely there's definitely places
that I go to now where it's just like
good lord one of them is New York City I
swear to God I mean really if I go in on
just a guest spot night if I go there to
do a show it's people who know me they
know what they're getting and then you
know it's it's actually easy but if I go
in and just pop in and do strike like I
will never ever get over having a joke
being groaned in New York City it's like
I'm just thinking like what the [ __ ]
happened in this play that's the whole
[ __ ] place it's like a giant Bed Bath
& Beyond now it's so nice it's so much
[ __ ] cleaner I don't know where they
put all those people because all of the
all of the the social ills that created
that they haven't solved there's still
drug addicts there's still prostitution
I just don't know what rug they swept
them underneath to because I know it
exists but now everybody's walking
around and like the [ __ ] Truman Show
and you literally stand on stage and
what [ __ ] blows my mind it's like I
always say I'm saying I'm 50 years old
like you guys should be shocking me you
guys they're all you're acting like a
bunch of old people on a [ __ ] cruise
ship like I'll be up in like oh you know
but what I love about that is only if it
it [ __ ] with their politics mm-hmm
because since the beginning of my career
you can say that a redneck
has sex with his own sister and you will
get an applause break and be carried out
the [ __ ] room and right there I'm
some sort of incest going on there
mm-hmm that's some sort there is right
but that's totally fine because it's
those people you can say whatever the
[ __ ] you want about them but then
everybody over here is is courageous and
they're a warrior and a [ __ ] I don't
know what else they are well we're
missing nuance right now and we're
missing conversation and it's absolutely
good and evil now it's absolutely it's
your your side or my side and there's no
real conference there's not enough
Patrice O'Neal's because I got to be
honest with you like if that guy was
still around he was like like sort of
the comedy bouncer or policemen mm-hmm
and to the point there was like people
who wouldn't work clubs that he was at
because and they would say because he's
a bully Ruiz of [ __ ] [ __ ] he was
actually he was just trying to make you
better and like the whole like I mean I
I miss that guy you know at least once a
week something will happen I'd be like
god I wish I could hear what Patrice
would have said about that and I can't I
can't [ __ ] imagine what he would be
thinking today with some of the [ __ ]
that and some of the people that say it
like the level of like I mean I hope I'm
not coming off as preachy because I
would never tell another comic or
anybody what they should or shouldn't be
saying you know if you asked my advice
I'd be like listen this and I always say
this is how I did it and it worked out
for me because with our business there
is no you start in the mailroom right
and then you get promoted here it's like
I always picture it's a giant field and
everybody's running in every different
direction and someday somebody you see
somebody punched through and everything
like oh that's the direction yeah run in
this [ __ ] direction you know so well
you actually said sign that I tell the
young filmmakers all the time writers
and directors and I find that when I
meet young writers directors and I have
to imagine it's the same for comics that
when you're young you imitate the people
that you admire
I moved to my first short films all you
would say is wow that guy really wants
to be Quentin Tarantino I get it you
love Tarantino and then and then and
after you imitate a bunch of the people
that you like
you you you realize that you've been
scared of saying something or writing
something or directing something in this
way that the back your head is telling
you to do it yep and you're embarrassed
of that voice and then and then every
once in a while you start to lean into
that voice and that's your voice and if
you yeah so if you can stop being scared
of it and stop imitating the people you
like and and actually start to grow a
little bit of confidence with the way
that you just naturally want to say
things that is the only way in yeah it's
the only authentic way and I think it
kind of it's not only for any art form
it's kind of any walk of life there's
the moment you stop being scared of who
you actually were born now you thought I
always said that that every comic on an
open-mic walks in with their voice and
then they get introduced and in that
walk they proceed to lose their voice
and then try to fight it because you go
up there right and it's like before you
got onstage I mean people ask you
questions and you just answer them at
least amongst your friends yeah and
you're totally yourself but that is such
an outer-body experience oh my god
taking the mic out of the mic Stan and
then you're just totally self-conscious
and then it disappears and then you'll
spend the next seven eight [ __ ] 20
years trying to find it again how long
did it take you hmm I would say I would
say I don't know I don't know somewhere
in the 2000s I started to get it and
then I but I feel like since like 2011
2012 I've really been me or maybe it's
just but you also changed so a lot of
times you look back at yourself 10 years
ago and you can't relate to yourself so
maybe I was being me but that's just who
I was then I don't really know but it
was how many years though all right say
why are you looking at yourself in
you're gone oh I know who I'm pretending
to be well my thing I started in 92 and
my thing was Brian Regan and then Dave
Attell was a huge one Dave Dave Louie
but I thought it's funny I didn't really
like there wasn't anything about Lois
where like he blew it
have like this cadence that got into my
head it was more his his presence when
he came on to the stem I want I always
tell the story he went on at the Boston
and it was like [ __ ] like the show
was just over it was like 2:00 in the
morning he was [ __ ] over it nobody
had even gotten a laugh in like 45
minutes everybody's just going up there
bombing and he just walked on stage he
is that booming voice and he did this
exaggerated wave they just went hello I
can't even tell how we did it but it was
so ridiculous and exaggerated and silly
that he just sort of broke him and they
started like laughing and then he just
went into his [ __ ] and immediately
started murdering and killing so hard
you would have thought we all did a good
job like keeping the show going right
and I remember seeing him do it shap L
do it Dave Attell do it Greer Barnes all
of these guys and that was the big thing
as a comics being so scared of the
village in the mid-90s where it was
Giuliani just taken over just parked
that police truck down in the [ __ ]
Washington Square Park but it's like you
know as people like you know dealing
drugs out front it was like you know the
[ __ ] that people saw on the way to the
show mm-hmm that's why the grounds in
New York blows my mind because it used
to be like what the [ __ ] and I do take
wake these people up after what they
just saw on the just just getting to
this club but I used to watch those guys
and just and watch them kill after
everybody bombed for like an hour and
just 2:00 in the morning start killing
like they were 9 o'clock at night in a
in a perfect spot and I remember just
standing back there gonna how to [ __ ] do
you do that mm-hmm like how do you how
do you get to that level but anyway I
don't have you sit here talking about
myself because you have you now your
next movie you're doing gonna be
directing the next Ghostbusters yeah
right so now you're going from this this
nuance thing that now you you've got to
do this this franchise move by the way
congratulations I mean that's that's a
huge one well I mean and it's not just
his last movie it's the last 20 years of
my life I you know like any son of any
father I just said I'm not gonna be you
and like went out and became a Sundance
filmmaker you know you know I
established myself at Sundance I played
festival many times as short films
established myself as an independent
filmmaker and and that's who I really
still see myself and if you would ask
any time in the last 20 years you know
are you gonna direct a Ghostbusters
movie my answer would have been no no
I'm an artist yeah that's just not who I
am right that's my dad you must have me
confused by all that garbage and and I
had an idea I've had an idea actually
for a while it was just a cool way who
directed the first one
my father your father did I'm the worst
dude like all I know is sports so your
dad
directed the first one right maybe we
start talking sports and I'll sound very
ignorant but graduations on the Super
Bowl I know that thank you I did a hell
of a job watching ya oh yeah yeah
waiting for my ring to show up oh yeah
my dad read my dad directed the first
and second Ghostbusters so wait a minute
did you wait and they recently made
another sis is the fourth one yeah my
father produced the one that came out a
couple years ago the one that Paul Feig
directed okay so has there ever been in
the history of Hollywood a dad who
directed the beginning of a franchise
and then his son comes along later and
directs another one no and there's a
good question and I probably should know
the answer to this and there's only so
many kind of father inside so basically
right now okay you got Lawrence Kasdan
is the guy who wrote Empire Strikes Back
raids of the Lost Ark and it was
actually a neighbor growing up and he
has two sons both are directors John and
Jake Jake most famously directed Jumanji
John co-wrote the Han Solo movie with
his father so you have that you guys I
saw that one no I saw them on a plane I
was like yeah and then and then Laurence
and his son write solo so you have that
father-son thing
other than that wait a minute Aaron
that's it's gonna drive me is it driver
Adam driver
Oh Adam driver are drivers in the is in
the kind of is in this addition to the
skywalker that's the one I thought
drivers in force awakens Adam drivers in
last chat I thank God I know you've got
Carl Reiner and Rob Reiner but I don't
think Rob Reiner ever directed anything
that is father established
I don't know maybe if like Sophia
Coppola does a Godfather movie I know
but she was in one she was in the third
one now okay South but when do you know
when do you when you're doing something
that [ __ ] big mm-hmm like I just
can't him like how far out do you have
to start with to keep that [ __ ] giant
pizza dough in the air as far as like
it's actually the crazy thing is we have
no time is we so I wrote the filming
secret with my writing partner Gil
Cannon we wrote it over the last year
while we were finishing up front runner
and we turned it in December and I have
to admit my presumption was it was gonna
be like any studio film that I had heard
about where they do years of rewrites
and they grind it into the ground that
never happens and I was kind of fully
prepared for this year to be a year of
maybe taking a little time off and you
know doing rewrites on ghostbusters and
instead this the studio read the first
draft and said yeah go make it Wow so
we're with with a very short runway
we're gonna be shooting you know this
summer good lord
coming out the following summer how long
will it take you to shoot something like
that I don't know I mean it'll take us a
few months and then we'll be in post and
for the first time I'll have set pieces
with visual effects and I'll be working
with a visual effects supervisor and you
know visual effects houses they'll be
creating ghosts and things like that
have you ever when you got into early on
in your career as a director did you
ever get into the Edit room and realize
you didn't have a shot you needed and
then like what the [ __ ] do I do now like
you oh I've realized that on every
single movie I mean you go into every
single movie thinking you know how to do
this job and you get to the edit and it
is humiliating and depressing and you
you watch that first cut of your movie
and and I've had you know I've had
movies that went on to be nominated for
Best Picture and the first time I saw
them I thought I will never get hired
again no one will ever let me direct a
movie again when they - yeah I mean look
the great no because I always says as I
can actor when I sit there and you know
when you first start especially as a
comedian when you exist in real time
20 minutes and you're done in 20 minutes
- then see how long it takes to get 20
minutes of film is something I had to
let I got to get into a completely
different mindset and when I saw like
all of the shots not necessarily on your
movie because I thought I liked the pace
you worked at they would there's been a
couple ones that I've worked in where
they're shooting so much stuff I'd
finally like why would they do and then
I finally just put myself into the
directors brain and I was like oh I bet
every one of them early in their career
went into the Edit room didn't have the
shot and that like [ __ ] haunts them
so I feel like they get in there they
get everything that they want and then
they're like then they start going okay
all right what where how could this [ __ ]
me you know all right let's let's not
know now let's do like a tracking thing
and all that type of stuff so and ever
since I did that I kind of now it's like
I understand the madness of it because I
was doing what most people do initially
was I was in my own head looking at my
own head like why isn't this going the
way I would do it even though I don't
understand what's going on like I just
recently did an acting gig and for the
first time ever I finally if I don't
know what happened it all came together
like I got it I'm like okay this
shooting the master now they're doing
this over and now they're going for a
two-shot and I could kind of and then I
started being like an actor going like
that they're not gonna be on me I mean
they're on me but they're not gonna use
this yeah so you know make sure this one
now this is one that they're gonna go
through counts so make sure this and
that I never had that I was just always
out there you know paging mr. Herman
mr. Herman you have a bunk right now I
would be I would be doing my close-up
acting on the [ __ ] wide and yeah
throughout the whole [ __ ] thing and I
and I would be working with these actors
going like this guy does even look like
he's [ __ ] trying and all of a sudden
that they'd be over me and all of a
sudden like home and I was like what is
going on here man this guy is like a
[ __ ] and he's like a schizo or
something I at this last one that I just
did it all it all
came together and and I and I ended up I
got it and I got I finally understood
what I was supposed to be doing and how
I could help the director and everybody
else and and I end up having the best
[ __ ] time even though I bitched about
it a little bit a cup not even a little
just every night like Jesus Christ
12-hour [ __ ] days I'm a comedian I
work one hour one hour days I found that
actors generally break down into two
groups and there's actors who are a
hundred percent aware of everything
that's happening around them and then
there's actors who have no idea what's
happening around them and they're both
valuable actors who are kind of
puppeteering themselves and know where
the cameras and know what the lensing is
gonna do and you know Clooney's like
that Clooney you know who's a director
himself will literally be like so you
wanted me to bring my right shoulder in
and I'm gonna look this way and when I
look all you know I have that one look
and you can't what lens are you one oh
you're on a fifty okay great I'll look
that way and he knows the whole thing
and then I've had actors who are equally
talented but like I've had an actress
exceptional Hector as' who mid-scene I
had to cut and I said you know you can't
stand there and she said why's he's
standing right in front of the camera I
had no idea Lilly who's just blocking
leverage it just stopped what is it
brilliance to that because they're so
lost in what they're doing so then you
have to adjust if when I can if I can
capture the best scenes when you have
one of each I find you have one actor
who knows everything that's going on and
you get the other who's wild and it's
like it's like you have one dance
partner who's keeping time and keeping
the footwork and the other one who's
just pushing them and it was just a
cereal and he's gonna give you stuff you
would have never thought of that's my I
probably don't want to know any more of
this because then it'll all be in my
head the next time I do it but it's
something I want to hang out with you
you gotta explain that lens thing
because I've heard a few actors be what
are you on a fifty all right see right
right like they know like the whole
thing I'm like I don't it's it's oddly
so simple I mean it really is just one
shows a lot and one shows less and one
has more and focus on one has less and
focus and they make you feel different
things and that and that's just it so
when you talk about all the things that
derive but there's an art to all of that
well you're you're you're either someone
who is sensitive or not you're either
someone and I think the same goes for a
comic you're either someone who's
sensitive
- no oh when I say this it makes the
room feel like this it makes them laugh
in this way versus that way and when I
use this word it makes them laugh and
this way versus that way and over time
you get to you know yeah I mean very
rarely but you get to someone as
talented as yourself who has an opening
I'll say you label for them an idea that
they're gonna start with but from there
on you're figuring your way out and
you're reading a room and you're
sensitive to it in the same way a
director is sensitive to alright if I
light it this way it'll make the
audience feel this way if I cut it this
way or use this music we use this shot
all the delay down to kind of my new
details and your your ability to grow as
a filmmaker is your sensitivity matched
with kind of growing technique right
well last question I'll ask you alright
and thank you so much for coming on this
has been fascinating listening to all
how all of this led you to be here so
with the Ghostbuster movie yeah I would
imagine that there's this whole thing
where you have to be loyal to the look
the vibe and the fans of the previous
and then you also have to want to put
like your stamp on it ha ha so how is
this like a hacky [ __ ] junket
questions like no no not at all and this
is knocking I'm not making the Junot of
Ghostbusters movies once again I don't
know that reference was a Super Bowl of
movies that is a that's that that was
that's fine my most famous movie like my
obituary will say Jason Reitman son of
Ivan Reitman director of ghostbusters
also directed Juno that will be my run
that's how my obituary starts it was
that your biggest movie yeah and it was
this kind of movie that we made for
nothing was a movie that we made for
like 7 million dollars and grossed
like 200 million dollars and so you made
like 30 grand on that I know and I made
nothing because he was my second movie
and I literally had nothing on it but he
always gets your studio made a fortune
on that movie they did really well and
it was the launching of Ellen Page in
Diablo Cody you wrote it and and really
is the reason why I have a career but
anyhow this is gonna be a love letter to
ghostbusters oh hi I love this franchise
I grew up watching had I consider myself
the first Ghostbusters fan I was like 7
years old
that movie came out and uh and I loved
it I want to make a movie for my fellow
Ghostbusters fan so it's a fans
yeah and and we're doing it in the style
like we just did this teaser for it that
we launched when we announced it and
even in that we went back to the work
files for the sound of the proton pack
and we went back to the stems of Elmer
Bernstein score for just where it says
at the end of the teaser it says like
you know summer 2020 we went back and
found the original like physical vinyl
letters that they used to create the
Ghostbusters poster in 1984 rescan them
then our titles guys reprinted them and
we filmed the titles not like in a
computer we shot
physical titles with a light and smoke
effect because that's how they would
have done it back in the day so we are
in every way trying to go back to
original technique and and make a and
hand the movie back to the fence that's
awesome well I'm looking forward to
seeing that and everybody can see the
front runner on iTunes where else did
you say was available I mean anywhere
you would normally go go go buy a
blu-ray go watch on iTunes and
particularly if you're someone who
doesn't like being told what to think
here is kind of a rare movie of nuance
yeah I love it all right Jason Reitman
everybody thank you so much for being on
the podcast Andy buddy